it is seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast and these are our top stories
opposites to the nature of god
the archbishop of canterbury set to
intervene in the realm over sending
immigrants to rwanda
surrender and you can live russia's
message to ukrainian forces in mariopol
as moscow claims the city is now almost
entirely under its control
i'm in ukraine where a deadline set by
russia for ukrainian forces in mariopol
to surrender has passed without
surrender
prince harry and megan are back on
center stage as they open the invictus
games
a warning that a shortage in hormone
replacement therapies could lead to
women buying medication from the street
running out of steam how the war in
ukraine is affecting britain's heritage
railways
in the sport liverpool reaching their
first fa cup final in 10 years after
beating manchester city at wembley
as for the weather for many easter
sunday will be fine with sunny spells
but outbreaks of rain will spread across
ireland and northern ireland into
western britain
and to quarter two we'll take another
look at the papers with the
anthropologist marianna hotter and the
presenter and writer matthew stadler
[Music]
morning all the archbishop of canterbury
is set to intervene in the row over
government plans to resettle asylum
seekers in rwanda justin welby will use
his easter sermon to say the plans are
the opposite of the nature of god the
home office has this morning defended
the move saying changes need to fix a
global asylum system sky's political
correspondent rob powell has the latest
the archbishop of canterbury will fully
enter this debate about the
controversial rwanda asylum seeker
policy he'll use his easter sunday
sermon from canterbury cathedral to say
that he believes the scheme is the
opposite of the nature of god um he'll
also say that easter should be a time
for repentance
and renewal not subcontracting out our
responsibilities now we know that justin
welby is someone that has got involved
in political debates in the past he'll
also talk about the war in ukraine and
the cost of living crisis in his morning
sermon but i think coming from the
leader of the church of england on
easter sunday from the pulpit these are
very strong words and criticism of this
rwanda policy
of course justin welby and also the
bishop of durham that's criticized the
policy both sit in the house of lords so
they'll both have an opportunity to have
their say on the actual legislation that
will underpin the rwanda scheme it's due
back in parliament next week
for debate i think in all likelihood
while there will be more changes
put forward by the lords to this
legislation with most mps likely to vote
it through and vote with the government
it will probably become law and go on to
the statute book i think the biggest
risk maybe for the government
in the short term anyway is the
possibility of there being a legal
challenge and it being disrupted in the
courts now the home office has replied
put out a response
to the comments from the archbishop of
canterbury in which it said that the uk
has a proud history
of supporting people in need but while
there's a global migration crisis
changes needed because of people
smugglers that are putting lives at risk
they've also pointed out that
that rwanda is a safe country and
they've also said that it's their
view
that this scheme would not contravene
international law we obviously know that
many people have been querying this not
only on a legal level but also on a
moral level as well
well the archbishop's comments come as
members of the royal family prepare to
attend services on easter sunday the
queen however will not be attending
as ongoing mobility issues continue to
limit her public engagements prince
charles and the duchess of cornwall are
also understood not to be there today
but in his easter address prince charles
has highlighted those affected by the
war in ukraine offering support to the
quotes millions of people who find
themselves displaced wearied by their
journey from troubled places wounded by
the past fearful of the future
russia says it will spare the lives of
ukrainian soldiers fighting in mario
paul if they lay down their arms today
the russian defense ministry says a
surrender window opened at 3 a.m uk time
president zielinski says if russia kills
troops in mario paul he will call off
peace talks well let's take a closer
look at the latest developments
russia has resumed scattered attacks on
the kiev region following moscow's
warning that it planned to step up
missile strikes on the capital
in mario paul itself the russian defense
ministry says it has now cleared urban
areas of ukrainian forces
and in his nightly address to his
country the president ukrainian
president said that the situation in the
encircled city is inhuman
but stops short of addressing russia's
claims of a surrender window adding he
remains in contact with ukrainian forces
there
sir
we will not abandon these efforts and
every day either i or the
commander-in-chief of the armed forces
or other military officials or the head
of our negotiating team are in
connection with our defenders of mario
paul daley
well president zielinski's words come as
the humanitarian situation in mario paul
continues to deteriorate
the city has suffered almost relentless
bombardment since the war began in
february sky's mark stone reports from
zapposia where he met a couple who
finally escaped from mariupol after 45
days under siege
behind the faces of those who have
escaped mariopol is the trauma of 45
days in hell
this is the story of the borax one
couple one experience let's go inside
and have a chat okay
oh
but replicated over and over we'll find
some some seats
the first thing people saw and we got
out of the hospital your
dead bodies in the streets it was
horrible
people
different people of different ages
sometimes whole families with children
because
there was the shell or the bomb and they
just got in their own place and they
were killed it was horrible
mariopol has been home for tatiana and
valerie for almost their whole lives
our apartment was on the 11th floor
so the bomb actually got into the
apartment above us into the 12th and
that apartment just
destroyed
itself and our apartment so
all our life is just ashes
and here it is number 95 as of stalker
street mariopol an image captured
shortly after it was hit on the 15th of
march
our city was a flourishing city before
now your city is
gone yes actually it's a ghost city
because we can you you go get out into
the street and you can see
the
skeletons
black blackened skeletons of nine
storied buildings
because they were burnt down and you we
don't even know how many people were
killed inside the hospitals were hit as
well and and and the school that you
taught in your english teachers both of
you
the school that you taught in that too
has been destroyed yes our school was
built in 1936
and it survived german occupation
yeah it didn't survive this no
it's somewhere here on a map they point
out school number 40 drone footage taken
in the last week shows what's left of it
the destruction here is breathtaking
imagine living it
we heard the sound of the plane and then
horrible boom and the whole
building
started shaking shaking we could see
that half of the building was
burned down or was just destroyed we
could hear people crying
it was horrible and the constant flow of
people who were trying to come to the
hospital to get some shelter because
they were
scared they brought children they were
wounded
they were brought without legs
wounded children killed children it was
horrible
we are only just beginning to discover
what happened and what is still
happening in mariopol the mayor says
more than 21 000 people have been killed
here since the russian invasion
they call themselves the liberators
they come and they say we have liberated
you
from what they have liberated us from
our life
they have liberated us from our
apartments from our money from
jobs from our jobs from our relatives
because a lot of people were killed
so what have you liberated us from we
had a good life for 50 58 years you
lived one life
and and then
at the end of march
you started living different life you
know
and you can't imagine how it could
happen
in a peaceful city
and so it is moments like this that must
raise spirits
reunions with old friends from a city
now gone
mark stone sky news in ukraine
i will in the last half an hour we have
as as we always do around this time uh
receive the latest update from defence
intelligence at the ministry of defence
and today they once again focus
on russian efforts in the east of the
country noting that they're redeploying
men and materiel there that the shelling
continues to take place at pretty high
volume in the east as well but it's the
last line that i think a number of
people will focus on though russia's
operational focus is shifted to the east
their objective remains the same they
are committed to compelling ukraine to
abandon their euro-atlantic orientation
let's speak now to our security and
defense editor deborah haynes joining us
once again from kiev good to see you
this morning deborah and what do you
make of this surrender window that has
been offered by the russians to those
remaining beleaguered troops at
ukrainian troops in in mariupol how
likely is it do you think that they will
take this opportunity if you go simply
by the rhetoric of zelensky not much i
would say
yes i think that's right
mario paul has been a city of war since
the beginning of this invasion it's it's
been the target of relentless
bombardments by russian forces in their
attempt to take the city and as mark's
report set out the toll that has been
paid by the residents of that city has
been almost too awful or too awful
frankly to comprehend that these figures
of 21 000 civilians killed and that
probably sadly is a conservative
estimate because nobody has been able to
get in there independently to verify the
full scale of the destruction but all
that time there has been this core of
ukrainian fighters defenders that have
been uh preventing russian forces from
taking full control of the city and
their their headquarters their their
their remaining forces are in this
industrial complex where they have um
fully fortified and set themselves up
for a battle to the end and
we spoke uh earlier in the week actually
to one of the soldiers there who said
that they were going to be fighting to
the end there was no sense that they
wanted to surrender and so russian
troops if they really are going to uh to
take this city are going to have to deal
with this industrial plant and so they
have given this window uh to surrender
to the troops there uh which started at
six o'clock this morning local time but
like i said we don't have any news that
that is happening uh the president said
in an interview yesterday that peace
talks would be cooled off should russian
forces eliminate in his words the
ukrainian troops in mario paul and so
you are really in this this deadlock
situation whereby
for russia to take the city they are
going to have to deal with this hard
core of ukrainian forces that are
showing no sign of surrendering yet
enduring utterly unspeakably awful
conditions they are besieged in this
plant there's no way to get their
wounded out
in terms of ammunition you can only
imagine it's a finite supply so it is a
desperate situation but it does mean
that the situation wider situation in
mario paul
could uh could soon crystallize in terms
of which way it's going to go will this
fight continue or will russia finally
capture a strategic victory in terms of
seizing a big city something it's failed
to do in eight weeks of war now
and all the while just one final point
to make there is this remove this
movement of troops from around here in
keys they have all gone from the north
they're regrouping in the east and there
is an expectation any day now that a new
offensive is going to begin across the
donbass region which will mark this
second phase in this devastating war
which will be a new challenge to
ukraine's military and the west that are
supporting them in terms of being able
to withstand this next assault
deborah many thanks
the russian ministry of defense has
released pictures that it says show the
rescued crew from the sunken cruiser
moskva
uh russia says that these pictures show
the commander-in-chief in fact of the
russian navy admiral nikolae yevmanov
meeting the crew in sebastopol sky news
cannot independently verify the date the
video was shot
ukraine claimed it hit the vessel with
two missiles russia said it sank on
thursday after a fire detonated
ammunition on board
some of the day's other news now north
korean state media says it has
test-fired a new weapon system that it
claims will boost the efficiency of its
tactical nuclear weapons south korea's
military says two projectiles were fired
off the east coast towards the sea on
saturday the official korean central
news agency said the test was under the
supervision of leader kim jong-un
and was successful
the prime minister is set to make a
long-delayed trip to india this week in
a bid to strengthen security ties with
the country boris johnson will meet his
counterpart narendra modi in new delhi
on friday with talks focusing focused on
defence and trades it will be mr
johnson's first major trip to india as
pm after previous visits were postponed
due to covet
14 people have been injured two of them
critically after a shooting at a
shopping mall in south carolina
officers in the state capital colombia
said the shooting occurred at the city's
columbiana center police say the
shooting was not random and that those
who had guns knew each other
the duke and duchess of sussex will
spend easter sunday watching sports on
the first full day of competition at the
invictus games harry and meghan
commended the bravery of the ukrainian
team in the opening ceremony on saturday
sky's ash nahuranak has this report from
the netherlands
on stage opening the same games where
five years ago they announced their
relationship please welcome my
incredible husband prince harry the duke
of sussex the duke and duchess of sussex
back on european soil for the opening
ceremony both delivering speeches of
empowerment and showcasing their unity
when i talk to my son archie about what
he wants to be when he grows up
some days it's an astronaut
other days it's a pilot but what i
remind him is that no matter what you
want to be when you grow up
it's your character that matters most
and nothing would make his mum and me
prouder
than to see him have the character of
what we see before us today
you
you as a community
have overcome immense challenges and
together you are healing and teaching
the world as you go their visit felt
just like old times but without the
royal titles it was however discreet
perhaps the couple keen to not become
the main attraction but as they met
international competitors it wasn't long
before words spread
it was this moment that delighted the
unsuspecting crowd the most
prince harry clearly up for the
challenge as the duchess also enjoyed
the show it's been a bumpy road for them
since quitting life as senior working
royals but the duke and duchess of
sussex have chosen to return to europe
in the public eye for a competition
founded by the prince himself and it's
clear they've been missed
the pair couldn't resist also hitching a
ride with these youngsters their
presence here is welcomed not only by
visitors but by competitors too
it's really great to see him on
on good form and and it's really good to
see him connect with
with the guys you know it's him it's
it's him
harry the soldier connecting with
with the boys and girls and it's really
good to see
of the 17 nations present there's one
whose arrival is particularly remarkable
the ukrainian delegation made it through
a war zone to get here among the team is
anna her mother tara was due to compete
this week but the military paramedic has
gone missing in mariupol the 18 year old
hasn't heard from her in over a month
actually i came here to
tell him the truth about what happened
to my mother and
like
screaming about it to the people
to
just
for they know the situation in my
country and what happened to my mother
in the spirit of the games it's the sick
injured and wounded competitors from
ukraine and other conflicts who'll be
celebrated this week a message of
solidarity aptly delivered in the city
of peace and justice
ashanaharanak sky news in the hague
time for the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
i'm afraid it is slowly changing from
the west through the rest of the easter
weekend but there is still plenty of
fine weather to be had today much of
britain having a dry start with some fog
patches the low clouds may affect irish
and north sea coasts ireland northern
ireland western scotland all will be
cloudy with spells of rain once any
overnight fog and low cloud clears the
bulk of britain will be fine and dry on
easter sunday it will be warm
although temperatures will be down a
notch under the hazier skies meanwhile
rain across ireland and northern ireland
will slowly push eastwards through the
day
despite apparently refocusing its
efforts on the east of the country
russia has resumed scattered attacks on
ukraine's kiev region following moscow's
warning that it planned to step up
missile strikes on the capital
joining us now at the founder and
director of the eastern europe security
institute at yulia osmolovska thank you
so much julia for being with us this
morning i really appreciate your time
and can we start with just the situation
where we where you are quite clearly the
russian forces have been
pushed back from the capital but they
continue to attack and they continue
to strike using artillery
yes you're quite right especially uh
with the recent developments when
the fraudmanship of russia had been
saying the
russians
expectedly are trying to do some sort of
revenge quite heavy and dance bombing
and shelling this is something that we
expect because uh in immediate range of
fight russians
tried not to do this because they don't
have quite enough professional capacity
to fight with ukrainian
army therefore what we expect right now
is uh some heavy missile strikes both on
kiev and on southern region so you're
quite correct in your assumptions
well how is it to be to be living still
in in some way which is
clearly a target an ambition for an
ambitious russian military offensive
well it's quite interesting uh for you
to understand that uh it doesn't create
a fear among
ukrainians it creates uh outrage with
what russians are doing and basically
i've been traveled this week also the
thousand regions to odessa to nikolai
and talk to officials there and what
they say that the people are ready to
fight
so we have enough manpower the only
thing we need is just heavy weapon with
long range
just to uh beat russians in that uh
right and for this long range we once we
obviously need the support from western
countries which were heavily lying on
um julie what do you make of this
situation in and around mario paul at
the moment of course the the russians
have offered what they're describing as
a surrender window telling ukrainian
forces there you'll put down your arms
and and you will survive i was listening
to president zielinski's address last
night you know if we go by the words of
the president it seems unlikely that
he's willing to take advantage willing
to surrender that part of his uh to
surrender that part of the country
no definitely no one is going to
surrender from a ukrainian part because
we feel enough power enough will of the
people to fight russians the only thing
we need right now is to have more
weapons
to withstand russians in this fight so
definitely the mood
uh and russians demands seems quite uh
strong and strange because uh
there are no obvious reasons for
ukrainians to surrender uh ukrainians
are quite well keeping the pace of fight
uh we've successfully covered the first
stage not letting russians uh to concur
the capital of our country therefore all
the fightings are going right now to be
concentrated in eastern animation and
also in south sudan and again i repeat
if we have enough
heavy weapons uh to uh withstand russia
and some thousand dimensions so
obviously we also be tr uh pushing uh
russians getting back if we have enough
weapons
um well julie i do hope that you your
colleagues your friends continue to stay
safe julia osmolovskova thank you so
much for joining us
uh let's get a little more now on the
archbishop of canterbury's intervention
and the row of our government plans to
resettle asylum seekers in rwanda uh ali
fortescue joins us now live from the
newsroom good to see you this morning
ali um like over the years that i've
been reporting i've become rather used
to the head of the anglican church
making political interventions but
justin justin welby's let's go up there
yeah you're right i mean i think it is
it's fairly rare for justin welby to get
involved in politics in this way but i
think what really struck me was just how
strong and how direct his language is
here about this idea of resettling
refugees in rwanda which we know has
been highly controversial this is his
easter sunday sermon and he's expected
to say and i quote that subcontracting
our responsibilities even to a country
that seeks to do well like rwanda is the
opposite of the nature of god who
himself took responsibility for our
failures so extremely clear and direct
their message from the archbishop of
canterbury this of course is one of the
most important days in the christian
calendar so he's expected to make that
sermon at the at canterbury cathedral
but of course um it feeds in i think to
the kind of broader narrative that this
is a home secretary that isn't doing
enough to help asylum seekers and we
know that there's been criticism too of
the government's plans to re-house
people coming over from ukraine
criticism that that hasn't been quick
enough and on this proposal to send
people to rwanda that's been criticized
as being unethical but also being
practically very challenging when it
comes to the cost and the legal
challenges that the government may well
face but the home office for their part
said that the uk has a proud history of
supporting those in need of protection
and our resettlement programs have
provided safe and legal routes to better
futures for hundreds of thousands of
people across the globe
however it goes on to say the world is
seeing a global migration crisis on an
unprecedented scale and change is needed
to prevent vile people smugglers putting
people's lives at risk and to fix the
problem of the brogan
global asylum system and remember this
of course is a home secretary under a
lot of pressure to fix a problem of
migrants crossing the channel in small
boats she wants to be seen to be doing
something but this plan has been
controversial and now just in well be
the archbishop of canterbury adam adding
his voice to that concern
thanks ali
menopausal women are being turned away
from pharmacies and are instead
resorting to buying their hormone
replacement therapy from other women
because of a shortage of supply of the
medication campaigners say it is just
another blow for women's health after
the government delayed plans to reduce
the cost of hrt prescriptions in england
sky's katie barnfield has been taking a
closer look
julie's work takes concentration and
skill
running her own business making beeswax
cosmetics
oh yes they're quite busy
she says she would struggle to manage it
without hormone replacement therapy so
it came as a shock when she was suddenly
unable to get her prescription
a friend of mine mentioned a few weeks
ago that she was struggling to get some
hrt gel and had to have the patch
instead but i didn't really think
anything of it
it was only when i went to our local
pharmacist here that they said oh sorry
we've run out
and i had about a days left by that
point
julie ended up taking time off work and
driving to four different villages to
get the medication
i was really starting to panic thinking
i'm gonna feel rubbish if i don't get
hold of this stuff pretty soon
claire hattrick runs a menopause support
group and says the current shortage of
some hrt products has led to women
becoming so desperate they're buying
drugs on forums or meeting strangers to
trade medication
we've got a problem here and it's
spreading like wildfire and it hasn't
been going on for weeks i've known about
this for about four months now and it's
getting worse women are going and
trading in car parks saying oh well i'll
give you a pump of this if i can have
some hrt patches it shouldn't be like
that it's never good to be using other
people's medication it should be
prescribed by a clinician whether that's
a doctor a nurse or a pharmacist and it
should be properly monitored we
communicate with the pharmaceutical
companies frequently and we're being
reassured that actually
the products will be fully available in
the near future
manufacturers have blamed the supply
issues on an increase in demand and
delays in making products caused by the
pandemic while the government says
alternatives to affected products are
available and they're working with
companies to resolve the issue
certainly me just from two days of not
having it i was starting to feel unwell
but for thousands of women like julie
these are medicines they simply cannot
do without
katie barnfield sky news
time for another look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and the weather isn't afraid slowly
changing from the west through the rest
of the easter weekend but there is still
plenty of fine weather to be had today
much of britain having a dry start
some fog patches and some low clouds
might just affect the irish and north
sea coasts ireland northern ireland and
western scotland will be cloudy with
spells of rain once any overnight fog
and low cloud clears the bulk of britain
will be fine and dry on easter sunday
with us once again to review the papers
the anthropologists marianna hotter and
the presenter and writer matthew stadlin
some good selections this time guys
let's crack on um marianne your story on
the front of the sunday times
and it is a story as the kind of the sub
headline points are that that is very
very reminiscent of that horrible
horrible tale from many years ago
thalidomide
yeah this is an absolutely shocking
story that honestly neil i hadn't heard
of before now and the number of babies
and families affected by this is
massively greater than the limit
thalidomide scandal so what it is is
it's an epilepsy drug called sodium
valproate that is um
prescribed to people to help them
control their epileptic seizures
since 1973
health officials and the manufacturers
so the pharmaceutical company that makes
this drug sanofi
have known about and and had concerns
over whether a woman taking this while
she's pregnant could cause um
abnormalities or and disability in the
fetus and then obviously the child when
it's born and this can be autism
learning difficulties in and physical
deformities and legs and hands and and
arms
are kind of born deformed as well as um
brain
skeletal and gut problems so this is a
really profound profoundly damaging drug
if you take it while you're pregnant
the the scandal comes in these first
warnings were um issued in
1973 and there have been um subsequent
inquiries reports published
peer-reviewed papers that have not
actually trickled through into
giving patients the information and
giving clinicians gps and neurologists
who are helping people control their
epilepsy the information that they need
in order to make decisions because
obviously you don't want to have
uncontrolled epileptic fits that's not
good for mother or baby but neither do
you want to be taking a drug that could
potentially cause deformities in your
unborn child
it is still the case that women are
being prescribed
this drug sodium valproate even now so
the most recent data is from march and
it shows that between april 2018 and
september 2021
247 women were prescribed this drug
which means that six babies a month
six babies a month now are being born
with deformities that could be
potentially avoidable
that's partly because these drugs are
being given to uh women in plain packets
and so the information leaflet isn't
there by pharmacists not only
no not not off the internet or anything
like that buy your gp or your pharmacist
plain packets or stickers stuck over the
warnings saying don't take this drug if
you're planning to be pregnant or you
are pregnant and this is an absolute
scandal um and there was a report in
2020 an independent review
which called for families affected by
this to be rewarded compensation it
doesn't change obviously the tragedy of
what's happened to their children or
what's happened to their family but it
helps them cope with the costs that
that
you know a lifetime of care require and
so far the government have resisted
they've they've issued an apology
they've said uh in the report it was
that it was disjointed
unresponsive and defensive response to
these families concerns but i think now
is the time that we all need to say look
no more these families need compensation
for a tragedy that was entirely
avoidable matthew take us to the front
of the uh of the observer the the prime
minister's rwanda plan has been getting
criticized from any number of directions
but with the the head of the anglican
church coming and he's getting getting
criticism from top down at the moment
from the guy upstairs
is a remarkable story because on the one
hand you might think that the prime
minister is sitting in checkers over his
easter eggs this morning incredibly
grateful that the fact that he's i think
the first prime minister ever to have
been found guilty of of breaking his own
law this week is not on the front pages
but then this dead cat that he's thrown
in the ring the idea of throwing rwandan
refugees or refugees to this country to
rwanda which by the way i think is
probably unlikely to work in practice
very few people i suspect will ever make
it after legal challenges but that is on
the front page not just of the observer
left leaning of course but also the
conservative backing sunday telegraph
and what justin welby is doing he's
using his his speech this morning his
sermon is easter sunday sermon which is
one of the two biggest sermons he'd make
each year the other one of course over
christmas is using that to condemn this
policy as basically unethical and going
against the judgment of god he says the
details are for politics but this goes
against the judgment of god and it goes
against the responsibility that we have
as a country to uphold our values which
of course are based on the christian
church
matthew
sorry when he says ungodly what on earth
does he mean if he's accusing the
conservatives of being evil why doesn't
he just say that
well i think we all know what
ungodly means
genuinely genuinely i don't know in this
context what he means by that what do
you take it to me
well i take it to mean lacking in
compassion i mean don't forget this this
is a weekend
where we celebrate the resurrection of
christ we celebrate the idea of hope and
yet here are people who are destitute
who are devoid of almost any hope they
struggle to get to this country they're
so desperate to get to this country
don't forget neil that they're prepared
to risk their lives in the channel and
what do we do with them or some of them
once they get here we send them to a
country rwanda which is presided over by
a president paul kagame who's been in
power since 2000
he was vice president before that dating
back to the 1994 aftermath of the
genocide he's accused of basically being
an autocrat if not a dictator and
accused of multiple human rights abuses
and we're sending these vulnerable
people after giving them i think a
five-day
a five-day opening window for a few and
we're sending them there that's not
about hope that's not about decency
that's not about about goodness it's
ungodly and i think immoral
and marianne can we skip ahead one and
go to your story in the mirror prisoners
being trained as football coaches what's
this about
yeah just a as a kind of little palette
cleanser because the news is heavy this
morning
so this is hmp featherstone which is
near wolverhampton and they've been
working with walsall football club um to
basically train some of the lags there
in being football coaches so they get an
accredited qualification they learn
enhanced life skills team building
skills all those good things that
actually mean you can change your life
and and build a kind of a good law
abiding life when you finally get out
and possibly also add value when you're
still in prison serving your term
and then
they used to apparently have a football
club featherstone prison football club
that they won the staffs county senior
league in 2014 uh perhaps unsurprisingly
at that point they played all their
games at home
[Laughter]
very very good marianne um your story on
the front of the independent matthew um
this this demand for action uh for
ukrainian refugees i mean we've been
talking an awfully good game in terms of
rehousing these people but when we
actually get down to it how many have
got here how many have actually found
homes
yeah and by the way that story that
marianne chosen great gag at the end i
mean that's about rehabilitation isn't
it it's about hope it's about giving
people a second chance but this story on
the front page of the independent we all
know there's been a huge outpouring of
public generosity brits being really
generous towards ukrainian refugees and
it doesn't seem to be met
by this rather venal government as many
would see it 250 000 people have signed
this independent-led petition which is
calling on the government to do more
provide more shelter provide more relief
for those who are suffering the
appalling treatment they've had been
dished out at the hands of vladimir
putin in ukraine let's hope it makes a
difference because 10 million people
let's not forget now have been displaced
in just over a month by putin's war in
ukraine and we have taken a tiny tiny
tiny fraction of those people here in
the uk and the reality on the grounds
here what the government has allowed us
to do doesn't match as they say that
generosity the outpouring of generosity
by brits themselves it isn't interesting
by the way neil that the ukraine is now
pretty much been pushed off the front
pages there's there's a worry that
there's empathy fatigue but what putin
is doing in ukraine it's still
absolutely appalling he's now attacking
kiev again after that quite remarkable
story this week when russia's flagship
in the black sea i think their third
most powerful warship seems to have been
struck by ukrainian missiles um matthew
marianne we will see you again for the
third round of papers after i forgot
that we were doing the show until 10
o'clock today we'll see you very very
shortly indeed for now thanks very much
um just a bit of breaking news reaching
us from inside ukraine we have of course
heard a number of uh reports of attacks
there a missile attack in the early
hours of sunday is said to have damaged
infrastructure in the city of brovary
near the ukrainian capital will have
more on that and the rest of the news
after this
[Music]
you